some 2 million women across the nation
forced to leave the workforce when
schools close during the pandemic and
just because businesses are back open
and schools resume doesn't necessarily
mean things will return to normal
well-being expert lorna borenstein has
the following message for managers heads
of companies that all the adjustments
your team's made during that time won't
magically disappear she says there are a
number of things ceos can do to make the
return on their employees easier
maybe they need no meetings before 8 30
in the morning maybe they need no
meeting zones from 5 to 7 p.m
maybe they need some flexibility i
remember when i used to work retail very
early on in my career i wasn't even
allowed to swap my hours with somebody
else only a manager could do flexible
time swaps what why
give people flexibility to help them
adjust so number one understand just
because you want them back and you know
back in the store back in the office
doesn't mean that they've got boom
everything back to the way it was
takes a little time bornstein also says
it's important to what she calls parent
loudly in the workplace she remembers
having to sneak out of her job to say
goodnight to her kids she says it's
important to show others you have a life
that you're juggling and it's okay to
talk about things that are real if
you're dealing with a crisis it's okay
to talk to your manager about it and she
says managers in turn should want to
create a safe environment for you to ask
for help